hey guys today we're gonna examine every
reason why it is highly likely that
Debian Hawks knew each other as children
now the other day I posted a rough
version of this theory on Twitter and a
lot of you seem to really agree with it
so I figured it might be worth putting
out an expanded version of this theory
in video form as we'll see throughout
the manga there is solid evidence to
support this idea but before I get into
it there will be spoilers for those of
you who aren't fully caught up so do
watch at your own risk
but with that said let's get into it in
Chapter 266 of the manga it was revealed
that Dobby nose Hawks his legal name
which is to car-b-que go now this was a
massive reveal because this name is top
secret and has never been stated by any
character in the series before even
Hawks himself was visibly shocked now
the reason this was a surprise is
because from about the age of six Hawks
was enrolled on a special government
program that required him to abandon his
legal name the aim of this program was
to create a special breed of hero that
had very specific skills and this is
evidenced not just by how Hawkes was
able to infiltrate the league of
villains but also by the fact that he
was the fastest hero in history to break
into the top three so the things that he
was taught on this scheme enabled him to
become a special hero with immense
status at a young age and that is going
to be really important later on in this
theory so keep it in mind
essentially what I'm saying is that the
aim of this program is to create the
perfect hero and following on from this
Hawks himself reveals that he looked
into the backgrounds of every member of
the League of villains and the only ones
he couldn't find information on with
dobby and sugar aki in Shigure Aki's
case is not that surprising as he's
essentially been off the grid since he
was a child
but in Debbie's case what reason could
there be is it possible that much like
hawks Dobby was put in a situation that
also required him to give up his legal
name at a young age remember this guy's
in chapter 31 of the manga in devastated
that the only reason he was having
children was to create a hero capable of
surpassing all my that was the sole
reason now his eldest son is Toyota
rocky and much like Shoto toya possess
immense power even more so than
endeavour himself now the trouble with
Toya was that due to his weak body he
was unable to control the flames without
hurting himself this is what caused
endeavour to get impatient and he began
having more and more children we showed
her being the perfect creation that he
had longed for however when we look at
this clip it's clear that when shota
began his hero training
was still very much part of the family
as we see him playing football with the
other siblings this is in direct
contrast to the common theory that I
hear a lot that endeavor train Toya so
hard that he ran away because once
shota's quark appeared endeavour
dedicated himself to training Shoto
specifically and he neglected the other
children so there's no real reason why
Toyo would run away if his dad wasn't
training him that hard anymore natsu
even says during the pro hero arc that
his father was almost like the perfect
stranger meaning that he wasn't very
active in the lives of his other
children and he also says that what
endeavour did to Ray Shoto and someone
else was not something that he could
forget now we already know what he did
to Ray and Shoto but this other person
that he's referring to is likely Toya
and endeavour admits in Chapter 252 that
he may as well have killed Toya himself
which implies that endeavour took some
action that indirectly led to his death
and this my friends is where it all
begins to tie together endeavour
neglected his other kids once Shoto
manifested his power right
but the fact remains that Toya was still
part of the family by default whatever
thing that occurred that turn Toyota
rookie into derby it happened during the
period of time in which endeavour was
dedicating himself to Shoto what this
means is that there was some kind of
third party that supposedly killed Toya
and this is backed up by endeavours
wording about how he may as well have
killed him endeavour also says that
while he never meant to neglect the
other kids
he ended up blaming other people and
dodging responsibility and that line
about dodging responsibility is so so
important the only reason he had these
kids was to create a new number-one hero
that could surpass all my and we already
know that Toya had the best firepower of
anyone given that this was endeavours
goal right creating this new hero the
only reason he put all his attention on
Shoto was because he had a nice hybrid
quirk and therefore had the best chance
dedicating all his time to training this
child he didn't have any time to Train
Toya
however given how much endeavour rates
toy his ability it would be pointless to
let that innate power go to waste
therefore endeavour dodged his
responsibilities by enrolling Toya on
the same special program the Hawks was
on in this way Toya would still have the
chance to ascend the ranks of hero
Society and it wouldn't require any
personal effort from endeavour himself
Toya would act as a sort of insurance
policy in case Shoto didn't succeed and
because endeavour was the number two
at the time it's possible that he was
actually approached to enroll one of his
children on this program and perhaps he
chose to put Toya in it due to his
potential whilst deciding to train show
to himself if this is the case it would
explain why Hawks couldn't find any
information on dobby because his legal
name would have been erased once he
joined the program it would also explain
why endeavour feels he has an indirect
responsibility for Toya's death at the
hands of the government and to support
this point there is something else we
should bear in mind in Chapter 266 dobby
attacks horse with his flames
even though twice is caught in the fire
Hawks then instinctively saves twice
from the fire due to his extensive hero
training Bobby then says that he never
worried about twice because he knows the
hero must always be ready to save a life
who taught him that how did that be know
that horses training would instinctively
kick in to save twice in the situation
if dobby had had that training himself
then it would make beyond perfect sense
and the way he says this like he knows a
hero must always be ready to save a life
it's almost like someone told him that
exact phrase when we remember that
Toyota rookie had a weak body that
wasn't suited to his powerful quirk and
the fact that he might not have joined
this program of his own free will it
becomes really clear why endeavour feels
responsible for his death what I think
likely happened is that Toya was pushed
too far during this stressful hero
training until one day he had an
accident that resulted in his supposed
death remember that his alias of dobby
literally translates to cremation so
it's possible that he chose his name on
purpose because essentially that's what
happened to him he was cremated in some
way how he survived this specifically is
a question for another time because we
don't exactly know what this accident
was but if the Public Safety Commission
did truly believe that he died as a
child this would explain why they don't
suspect dobby of actually being Toya at
least as far as we know if everything I
just mentioned is the case then we can
clearly see why shota wouldn't remember
his big brother despite coming
face-to-face with him during the forest
training camp they barely spent any time
together as children before Toya was
shipped off to government hero school
whilst he was there he was then believed
to have died but in reality he was just
horribly scarred nobody with knowledge
of Toya's death would have any reason to
believe that he survived and crucially
just because dobby has a similar quirk
it doesn't necessarily mean that they
would automatically think is the same
guy especially given that with all these
scars
must look so so different and also his
hair is black now so that's one thing
bringing it back to the overarching
topic of this video why do I think
Debian hooks into each other as children
well in addition to Dobby knowing Hawks
his top-secret government name we see
that when horse is asking Dobby who he
is the manga flashes back to hawks is
childhood where we see hawks enrolling
onto this course as he holds an
endeavour toy he says that he's ready to
become a hero like the man who saved him
from this we learned that not only was
Hawk saved by endeavor as a child but
that this specific memory is what
appears to Hawks as he's thinking about
who dobby could be this means that
there's some kind of connection between
Dobby and his time during the hero
course Hawks then arks this question
again and his facial expression when he
does this is very bold it's someone
who's not messing around
however once Dobby replies and tells
hawks who he is
his demeanor completely changes to one
of complete shock he literally like he
can't believe what he's just heard and
whilst we as an audience do not see what
debbie says to him based on hawks his
reaction it's clear that the name does
mean something to him so given the hoax
his name is a government secret but
Dobby knew it anyway and given that
Darby's real name is unknown to even
shigaraki yet Hawk seems to be familiar
with it there's undoubtedly history
between these two Toya was the eldest
Todoroki sibling which makes his current
age about 24 as his sister is 23
meanwhile hoaxes Canon age is 23 bearing
that in mind it's possible that this
special government program began with a
handful of students of which Toya and
Kaye go were part of remember that this
training is stated to be super hard so
it's unlikely that the government would
put all their faith in just one child
when it's possible that after a few
years of intense training a child could
just give up and say they don't want to
do it anymore so it makes sense to have
a select group of students potentially
maybe 2 to 5 additionally because these
kids are so young it would be stupid to
deprive these young children of social
contact with people their own age
especially because top heroes are
generally popular and sociable people so
what I'm thinking is that it's likely
that these two became friends and could
you imagine how excited he would have
been to meet the son of the person that
he idolizes the most on this government
training program they would have learned
that a hero must always be ready to save
a life which Dobby and hawks are both
well aware of in the present day but it
is possible that this terrible
experience to artificially manufacture
the perfect hero
what cause Toya to become disillusioned
with hero Society dobby says that he
believes there's no such thing as a true
hero in this world and that he is the
manifestation of stains ideology what
that potentially means is that this
experience on this hero cause is what
created this belief because essentially
they're manufacturing fake heroes like
hawks as he is now he is a great hero
but the fact is that he's almost been
manufactured from a young age to be what
he is and that is why he never trusted
him from the start
not only does he know who he is but he
also thinks of people like hawks is the
embodiment of everything staying hated
so to recap we know that dobby Squad
literally burns his flesh in addition to
that we know that young Toyota rookie as
a child his quirk wasn't really suited
to his body and it couldn't handle the
firepower this means that the training
he went through on this government hero
course could have resulted in a fake
death of sorts in that way Hawks would
have believed that his friend Toya was
dead the whole time and so would have no
reason to suspect that dobby was
actually that person in addition Toya
would have no existing records due to
his participation in this program what
that means is that when Hawkes looked
into his backstory and when Gran Torino
looked into his backstory neither of
them could find any details it would
also explain why they seemed to know
each other's names and why endeavor felt
indirect guilt at Toya's death because
essentially he didn't cause the death
but he kind of put the things in motion
that allowed it to happen
finally it provides an additional reason
why Shoto doesn't remember much of his
older brother but with that said that's
my theory on the matter it's possible
that maybe dobby was involved on the
scheme after Hawkes was as we know the
hoax was on it from around the age of 6
whereas in this clip here I think Toya
is probably around 11 or 12 years old
however in saying that it's possible
that Toya was on this secret program at
the time and potentially maybe he was
allowed to go home on weekends or
something there's a few small details
like that which may need clarification
and if you guys think you have the
answers then please by all means let me
know in the comment section below or in
the other hand if you think it's not
possible it'll all be sure to let me
know that as well thanks for watching
and peace out